cd projekt red has just announced a
massive new update for cyberpunk 2077
let's talk about it
as part of cd projekt's major news
briefing about cyberpunk 2077 today the
company announced and launched a free
trial for the action role-playing game
to give players a taste of what's new in
the massive 1.5 update the free trial is
available across playstation 5 and xbox
series xns right now it lets you play
for up to 5 hours and the trial itself
is available for 30 days cd projekt also
confirmed that all progress from the
trial will carry forward should you
decide to pick up the game during a live
stream a developer joked that some
people will find a way to beat cyberpunk
2077 within the five hour limit but
that's not representative of how most
will play cyberpunk 2077 is marked down
to 30 right now on xbox and 25 on
playstation so anyone keen to pick up
the game can do so at a nicely
discounted rate
the free trial will let players check
out what's in the 1.5 update and there
is a lot cd projekt said with the update
cyberpunk 2077 takes advantage of the
additional power of the newest
generation of console hardware allowing
for ray tracing features in 4k with
dynamic scaling faster loading times and
a variety of other visual and technical
improvements during the live stream
developers discuss how a ton of stuff is
being changed in the 1.5 update
including reworked talent trees if you
already played you can reset perk points
and redistribute them perks that were
not very useful have been removed
including one that prevents players from
being detected underwater new perks have
been added too including one called
looking sharp that enhances your skills
with throwing knives some of the new
perks have been purposely designed to
give players the ability to play more
aggressively and fast paced without
necessarily needing to use cover
although some melee builds could already
do this in general cd projekt says the
new perks should help players find new
play styles additionally the ai
characters are better and smarter while
the driving model has been changed as
well to make cars feel heavier crowd ai
has changed too as some npcs will have
weapons and might attack you in certain
situations additionally the 1.5 patch
for cyberpunk 2077 will let players
change their appearance mid-game players
can visit the mirror in their apartment
to change up their look there are the
same character creator options from the
start along with new options for makeup
the patch also adds a new website to
your apartment's computer called easy
estates which allows players to change
up the look of their apartment choosing
from six different options there are
also four new brand new apartments to
choose from spread throughout night city
the devs also spoke about how the patch
includes some new mysteries for players
to uncover fans will be able to discover
these secrets on their own as the studio
did not give any indication as to what
the secrets might be or where to find
them also included in the patch is a
guitar in your apartment that you can
play 80s themed songs on the sequences
are animated so that your fingers and
hands are moving as they would if you're
playing a real guitar what's more is
that 1.5 on pc adds the ability to
simply walk through night city
previously you were either moving at one
speed or sprinting the patch is also
going to be expanding on cyberpunk's
romance options with players now able to
more regularly send messages to
potential romantic partners successfully
romancing someone will let you stay in
their apartment as a safe house too and
if you want to see the full list of
patch notes then you already know you
gotta go check out gamespot.com
now if you're trying to upgrade and
transfer your save file to the ps5 then
there might be a couple more steps that
you'll need to do assuming you already
own a digital copy of cyberpunk 2077 on
ps4 you'll start by navigating to the
game on your ps5 from there select the
three dots or click on the free ps5
upgrade box on the right side you'll
then be taken to the playstation store
to purchase the ps5 version though you
won't be charged for it with the
purchase complete you can specifically
choose to download the ps5 version
in terms of transferring your save the
process varies depending on whether
you've previously played the ps4 version
on your ps5 if you are playing on a ps4
it seems you'll need to update that
version of the game which then allows
you to upload a save file to the cloud
that can be imported on ps5 this doesn't
require playstation plus as typical
cloud save functionality does but only a
single save can be moved in this way if
you have different files at different
points in the game you won't be able to
move them all in one go fortunately if
you've played the backwards compatible
ps4 version on ps5 previously you can
just download the new ps5 version and
your saves will all be present
automatically without doing anything the
full ps5 version weighs in at 56 gigs
how do you think these new changes are
going to impact the game and does it
make you want to hop back in and play
let me know in the comments and of
course thank you so much for watching
leave a like subscribe and we'll see you
tomorrow
you